I know we spoke earlier but now we're
actually live on periscope so our
audience is watching live and they
specifically asked for you oh no because
they saw you on TV as we talked earlier
you were under the tarp oh yeah what is
it if you had a message to tell them why
are you out here what would you say good
could I kind of just asked who my
audience is yeah so these are all the
people that are those hearts are you
yeah okay all right northern Arizona I'm
a I'm a rancher from you northern
Arizona I I love the desert I love the
high desert this is beautiful country
and even more beautiful I imagine in the
in the summertime but but I I love to
ranch I love my kids you know I love
being outdoors I love run horses that
I've taken care my cows and you came
here to support the Hammond family that
ranching family who's back in prison
again second time for the same that is
truly bad for her family let me tell you
why why it really touched my heart
strings if you want to know as Dwight
Hammond is the same age as my father
he's 75 and my father is still
physically fit enough to be able to ride
with me he's a better Roper than me by
far a better offer than me don't ask me
with the cows but in five years now
maybe his health will no longer allow
him to spend that time with me a son and
so here's the federal government's come
in and has taken those last five years
of Dwight Hammonds or those five
precious years where he could spend with
his family and throwing him in prison
where he's already served time for for
what for burning you know these few
acres of brush to man I just can't
understand why a government would do
that she a good citizen I didn't
understand that and so I've come here to
just support him and try to to see that
he's doing well you're a popular guy
I know I know taking a lot of media
requests and we really do appreciate
your time you have any other questions
audience we asked you this earlier but
audience knows are asking what you think
about the the native land question so
the fact that the Paiute came out
yesterday and services our ancestral
land they're desecrating it we want them
to leave what do you say what I want to
say is that anybody that feels that they
have a claim to to national natural
resources stuff we please that all those
voices need to be honored and heard I
have native blood in my own veins
I understand the fight of the natives I
actually was raised on the Navajo
reservation all right
I was I was a we'd actually traveled to
the ranch on the weekends but I was born
and raised on the reservation so so
anyway I understand that I don't
understand all their specifics I just
understand in a broad term and I'm
everybody should have a voice mr. Fenty
who a lot of people saw you that night
on the news sitting under the blue tarp
but you know some people thought it was
funny I didn't understand I want to give
you a chance to tell people what exactly
you were doing okay and why and why you
have a rifle with you okay and and I
probably won't answer some of those
questions but I'll tell you what in that
particular night we had information that
the federal agents had warrants for my
arrest you're specifically lavoy finicum
yeah and that they were coming to serve
that and we have people down here that
that were sleeping and and stuff I
didn't want them coming down here
kicking in doors in the night and
putting lives at risk and so I wanted to
be out there in the spotlight so they
could certainly see to see where I'm at
and so I stayed there all night didn't
didn't go home I didn't go over sit by
the fire it was raining sleeping and I
was getting wet yeah I got I hope I
didn't maybe just you sleeping all the
time and so it's freezing on me and so I
needed to keep that off that freezing
rain not snow now but it's freezing rain
that night and so I was there so that
everybody could see imagine this the
spotlights a lot of people around the
country looking at you guys and saying
why do you need to have guns why are you
armed in there they just you'd
understand the optics of that and how
would you answer yeah again as I said in
the in the press meeting is that that we
should never ever ever point guns at
each other
and that the guns are only only for her
for personal protection and and and I
just want to leave it at this particular
time one of the things that is a huge
issue we heard from the town people from
you guys is what what people are saying
is the plight of the ranchers and the
fact that a lot of people here making
their living off of ranching off of
logging and their their gripe with the
government is that they feel like it's
directly attacking their bottom line and
their livelihood
let us talk about the actualities here
this county in Kearney County in Oregon
is huge big it's almost as big as its
biggest some of the state's back east
that's so push so your audience can
understand the size of this land so when
you've learnt learn 200 acres of brush
and throw a citizen in prison when your
your the land masses is this county is
like a state back east it is insane but
this county used to be the most wealthy
county in the state of Oregon though the
wealthiest lumber industry lumber mill
was here in this county in the whole
United States now that is all gone
Harney County is now the poorest County
in in Oregon why is that because the
government has come in and seized the
natural resources and has locked the
residents off from that there was over a
hundred ranchers here that have they
have taken by one means or another
purchased forcing or intimidating or
whatever and then the most current one
is now happening with happens they're
losing theirs and parts of theirs anyway
to the federal government so every year
their land mass the holdings has
increased and then they hold these
resources and and we don't have they
don't have free access to now I have my
own things that I deal with with the
government in my own ranch that I
struggle with access to my own resources
so I understand this so when the county
and the state of Oregon needs to be the
ones that is the proper government to
handle these resources not a federal
government you know on the other side of
a continent coming here and telling the
citizens of their own state in their own
County how to do this and then holding
them holding all these resources so it's
just amendment I just want to give a
little bit of background here so in the
state of Oregon about 53% of the land is
controlled by the federal
yesterday we were at the town hall that
the sheriff called where we heard a lot
of different people from the community
it was full of his packed of hundreds of
people showed up a lot of them said that
they don't agree with your tactics at
all and that they want you guys to leave
but some of them do appreciate the fact
that this group brought the spotlight
onto this community and you know they
said things like rural poverty which
from our research we've read is a
greater than urban poverty in parts like
that like here in the West um is ignored
and it doesn't receive any attention and
that these what they say are their
grievances with the government over land
issues over their livelihood are
important issues and they appreciate
that they have now been brought to the
fore but then the question is mister
finicum how does this all get resolved
what's the point of this all that's why
we're actually working very diligently
members of the community are coming here
on a daily basis where we are
interfacing with them on how to do this
and and that that we me I want to get
back home to taking care of my own ranch
and so my me personally I want to leave
as soon as possible but I will stay here
as long as necessary to help these
ranchers resolve their plight just as a
neighbor one neighbor to another
neighbor so as long as necessary as soon
as possible and you're hoping not to
fire your gun
oh we're not no no no me no no fire
again nobody's gonna fire guns no I I I
want to keep everybody safe you know law
enforcement lives are precious they have
family members they may have loved ones
just as we do and so there's never any
no there's never any need of that if
there's no other questions I'll close it
out thank you so much this is lavoy
finicum i right guess you guys want to
see him cuz you saw him on the news yeah
this is I this is I the guy under the
tarp he's come from Arizona I have
that's why it's no colder here to take a
stand with these guys he's staying with
them inside yes and you can't tell me
how many people are in there though
please okay he won't tell me how many in
there bit but but they're here and look
out for our peace on aj+ wharf more with
him